>> Now the output from texture packers is actually going to be a JSON file. We
will need to load and parse the data in this file, in order to render all our
sprites on the screen properly. Now, for each chart in the atlas, the JSON file
lists a nice set of data, that allows us to understand more about this chart.
For our purposes, we're really only concerned with two things. The first, being
the name of this chart. Now, this was the name of the original loose asset
before it was packed inside of our atlas. And secondly, is the data here in the
frame parameter. Now, frame has 4 items that we actually care about. The first
two, x and y, represent the top left corner of the chart inside of the atlas.
The next two are width and height, which represent the size of this chart in the
atlas itself. Now, we're going to use all 4 of these values to actually draw
this chart to our canvas. Now, we've given you a sample data file to parse
that's actually part of the grid scheme. What we'd like you to do is use this
data to load the assets into our sample by filling out the parseAtlasDefinition
function in the sprite sheet class.